i think that was a very relevant topic
right now is
empowerment
sovereignty what we are and where we're
going so one of the things that you say
so many times is that we're advanced
beings that have a self-regulatory
system and so you know what when you say
that we're an advanced being
explain that and in relation to what you
know we just covered a lot of ground you
just asked a lot of questions and the
truth is
that they are all related and there can
be no digression because we are holistic
beings living in a holistic universe
part of all that is and that is the
fallacy for the way that we
we try to approach so many of our
problems the fallacy that we are somehow
separate from one another separate from
our world
uh and powerless victims of our
environment
and i think one of the things that's
happening right now danica the if you
know if you're going to have a global
pandemic it's good to have it in the age
of the internet
because the internet has allowed us to
stay connected and it's allowed us to
access
information in ways that we we never
have in the past
and part of that access i think is the
answer to to the question that you just
asked so i'm going to begin the answer
by simply saying there's a battle that
is unfolding
in our world right now on multiple
levels
right in front of our eyes we all know
there's a battle for our thoughts that's
very obvious the media is battling
to inform and guide the way that we
think about ourselves and our
relationship to the world and how we
respond to the pandemic and the economy
and uh race and all the other things
that are up for us right now there's
that battle
but that battle is based upon a battle
for our beliefs and that battle is
playing out in academia it's playing out
with what we teach our kids
about who they are and the way that they
solve the problems of the world that
come to them from from the time that
they're very young
the battle for our beliefs
uh
where did we come from are we an
accident of lucky biology or is there
some intentionality
underlying
our existence i mean that's a huge
question is the universe dead and
unconscious and inert or is the universe
alive and intelligent and connected
uh that battle is playing out
there's a battle for our bodies and i
think we're all getting that what does
it take to get healthy what's it take to
stay healthy what do we have to give our
our babies within moments of when they
emerge from the womb when they come into
this world
we are conditioned to think that they
have to have something outside of
themselves
in order to survive all those battles
are playing out but i want to tell you
they're all static they're noise
and they're covering what i believe is
the deepest battle of our time
danica it's a battle for our very
humanness our very humanness is on the
line right now because for the first
time in recorded human history we have
the technology that can steal our
humanness from us
in ways that some people aren't even
aware of and other societies and
cultures are adopting very very quickly
and i'm talking about computer chips and
planted into the human brain and
chemicals injected
into the body and wires under the skin
and the problem the problem
with this technology that's moving so
fast
is that when we give our natural
humanness away when we give away our
biological potential
to technology our body begins to atrophy
with respect to those potentials so if
we're implanting chips in our brain our
neurons we've all heard this before use
it or lose it biology you hear this all
the time
our neurons begin to think they're not
needed anymore and so they stop
producing in one generation the next
generation they become uh
an appendage of something that used to
be we're not using them anymore
and for the first time in 5 000 years of
recorded human history the technology
has the power to forever change our
species and the question and this i'm
laying the foundation to answer the
question that you asked
the question is and i would never
tell anyone or try to convince or
persuade anyone to or not to use the
technology but here's the key
the key is how much of ourselves do we
want to give away to the technology and
lose forever we can't answer that until
we know who we are and that brings us
back to the very first question that you
asked and it i gotta tell you it's where
the scientific discoveries are coming so
fast and furious uh in
these obscure technical journals that
very few people get to see but they're
based upon peer-reviewed science and
they're writing a new human story and
that new human story is what the covid
pandemic is pushing us to understand so
i'm going to stop right there and ask
does that make sense first of all yeah
of course it does yeah so the i think
one of the things uh
that we're beginning to understand we we
have been conditioned
for a couple of generations now to see
the human body is a flawed organism
carbon-based life
in general and the human body
specifically is somehow flawed
and
because of this flood that we need to
build things outside of us
that will help us to become the best
versions of ourselves to become
the achieve our greatest potentials
whether it's athletics or whether it's
mental or emotional capabilities all of
these things
so this is the path
that
that technology is following very very
quickly and what we're seeing
is that the technology has advanced
faster than the morality
of how we apply it in our lives i just
give you a perfect example what i mean
by that
a couple of years ago
scientific papers began describing
the ability to edit
the dna
of an of a fetus inside the womb of a
living woman just the way you would edit
a a document in a word processor on the
computer so on the word processor you
can you can add or delete words you can
highlight the entire paragraph
cut it paste it somewhere else
we now have editors where the the genes
come up on the computer screen and you
can highlight and delete and merge and
remove
and rearrange genes in the dna of a
living organism to optimize and perfect
that organism
while it's still in the womb before it's
ever born
and the question is
whose idea
of what is optimum
do we begin to use to do something like
that well well this was all theory
they were doing it in the lab until
2018.
in 2018 there's a chinese scientist that
very proudly said holding the baby in
his arms here are our first gene edited
human babies
he had done
in real life
what had been done in the laboratory in
theory and in tests and the scientific
community came down on him like a ton of
bricks
because they said wait a minute
just because we can
doesn't mean that we should and we see
this time and time again
with technology where the technology
advances just because we can implant
a computer chip into the human brain
that connects us with a hard drive of
our computer with no wires
no keyboards
and allows us to download information
does that mean that we should and we
cannot answer those things danica until
we begin
to understand who we are so these
discover this is the way science works
the discoveries are pushing science to
understand who we are and what they are
discovering is a mind blower
because what they're i'll just say it
and then we can unpack it
what they're discovering
i'm going to say it like this
we have yet
to
discover any technology
built outside of the human body that
does not mimic what we already do in the
cells
and the neurons and the organs of our
body except we do it better
we are what is called a soft
technology so rather than thinking of a
hard computer chip in wires and
chemicals
we're talking about neurons
and
and fluids ion potentials moving across
the membranes of cell walls and
crystalline bone structure
and
when we begin to understand what that
means
and the ability our innate ability to
self-regulate
this technology
that's the mind blower because what it
says
is that yeah we we can do these things
in the technology but the technology
maybe is reminding us
of who we are to push us in that
evolutionary direction